quand mon audition à deux voix si elle a
été diffusée en février
le direct après j'ai vu des captures
d'écran de mon compte personnel et je me
dis mais pourquoi en fait on allait
fouiller mon compte et pas celui de tous
les autres enfin comme s'il n'y avait
que moi qui s'est intéressé de savoir ce
que j'avais pu faire dans ma vie
personnelle et je pense sincèrement que
c'est parce que c'était moi parce que à
la télé ils ont vu mes filles qui
arrivent qui chante en arabe les cas
natures mortes qu'on allait fouiller
dans mon compte autrement on l'aurait
pas fait l'année dernière j'ai été
repéré par un des castors de l'émission
devos france pour participer à
l'émission the voice et à la suite donc
de mes vidéos postées sur youtube j'ai
été repéré par la prod et j'ai passé
l'audition à l'aveuglent l'année
dernière ensuite après l'audition à la
veuille que j'ai réussi j'ai eu les
quatre coachs qui se sont retournées
j'ai été j'ai poursuivi avec la deuxième
étape je suis plus comme on l'appelle
j'ai été sélectionné puis la troisième
étape ou encore une fois j'ai été choisi
par mon coach à l'époque mon coach
c'était mika donc j'ai été choisi pour
aller au live et en février 2018 quand
il ya eu la diffusion de des auditions à
l'aveuglé j'ai chanté a déduit ya et
cette chanson a créé une bande à la fois
une vive émotion mais en même temps une
hystérie donc les gens ont beaucoup
apprécié ma ma mon interprétation de la
chanson que j'ai fait en anglais et en
arabe
donc c'était un choix de ma part de
mixer deux langues pour mixer deux
cultures mixer vraiment cette différence
que je veux mettre en évidence dans au
travers de ma musique et je suis allé
sur scène avec ce turban et
et donc ça a créé une belle polémique
que peut-être vous avez entendu parler
et cette polémique et a démarré à partir
du moment où certains partis d'extrême
droite ont sont allés dénicher des
tweets sur mon compte facebook
personnelle que j'avais posté sur mon
compte facebook où j'avais posté en fait
en 2016 j'avais posté des choses sur les
attentats à nice parce que j'étais
révolté comme tout le monde et donc
s'est enchaîné plein de petits petits
grand article sur moi en train de me
descendre de dire des choses immondes à
mon sujet et tout ça m'a valu donc une
une
un questionnement que je pouvais pas
supporter donc j'avais pris la décision
l'année dernière en février de quitter
l'émission et c'était à contrecoeur j'ai
été boycottée de partout les maisons de
disques ne voulait pas signer avec moi
alors que j'avais eu des promesses avant
l'émission et bien sûr après impôts et
mick pas tout s'est envolé
c'était comme si je valais plus rien
j'étais devenu en fait par exemple il y
avait des sujets comme le danger de la
parole sur les réseaux sociaux hashtag
mesnel le la place de la femme musulmane
dans la société française hashtag mène
elle en fait toutes les causes étaient
bonnes pour s'appliquer à moi à la suite
la polémique j'avais l'impression d'être
un objet de représentation de plusieurs
causes au delà d'être mesnel mesnel
française chanteuse je devenais mesnel
symbole de je tenais un symbole symbole
de la femme musulmane
peut-être parfois même converti on
inventait d inventer des parcours
religieux ont inventé des origines
carrément je devenais fille qui était né
en syrie alors que je suis né en france
j'ai grandi en france
voilà en fait carrément je devenais ce
que je n'étais pas et bien plus que ce
que j'étais
au début j'ai fait le blanc dans ma tête
j'ai tout laissé de côté j'ai dit mais
c'est quoi ça ils sont ils sont fous
c'est jeu pour cadre les choses je suis
menez j'ai 22 ans et je chante et c'est
tout je chercherai un d'autres je suis
pas là je défends pers
je suis pas féministe je suis pas
islamologue je suis pas philosophe et
voilà donc jamais l'impression d'être
devenu en un jour une j avais 15
casquette
aujourd'hui je mens je m'intéresse même
pas parce que j'ai vraiment mon cap où
est ce que je veux aller et qui je suis
je le définis
j'ai défini qui j'étais maintenant
comment on définit à l'extérieur ça
m'intéresse pas après mon passage à
l'émission j'ai voyagé aux états unis au
canada et
je me suis rendu compte en fait que
ailleurs il ya peut-être un peu plus
d'ouverture d'esprit que en france
notamment par rapport aux as par rapport
tout simplement à la façon de s'habiller
quand on s'habille d'une certaine
manière en l'occurrence j'ai un turban
oui ça me regarde jean vit pourtant être
son banc je représente que ma personne
je prétends pas représenter une
communauté ou qu'elle n'importe quel
autre groupe social et est en fait en
france on j'avais cette sensation qu'on
était obligé de si tu t'habilles comme
ça alors forcément tu veux être
porte-parole
mais j'ai jamais dit que je voulais te
porte parole quoi que ce soit laissez
moi tranquille et à l'or et aux états
unis si jamais ces questions sur un
pourquoi tu un turban et pourquoi à mais
ça veut dire que tu es si donc toutes
les suppositions qu'on fait à partir
d'un simple d'une simple apparence gelée
par trouver aux états unis par contre
j'ai trouvé en france
je pense qu'en france on a un esprit
encore un peu conservateur on est un peu
attachés à notre bonne france notre
bonne langue française on n'aime pas
trop ce qui est enfin on a peur de
l'inconnu je pense je pense qu'en france
on est très on a peur de ce qui est
différent nous et quand j'ai voyagé au
canada et aux etats unis ont clairement
j'ai senti que le multiculturalisme et
quelque chose d'accepter et de tolérer
et être différent c'est pas être méchant
c'est pas être une menace si la laïcité
c'est respecter les convictions de
chacun va dans ce cas là je crois que
alors ça c'est moi qui ai pas compris la
laïcité soit vraiment la france a un
problème avec ça mais je ne sens pas la
laïcité en france
enfin je la sens pas appliquées
correctement un an après je me dis que
j'aurais absolument rien fait
différemment parce que
mais attention mais attention toujours
été bonnes je me considère pas être
parent de d'un esprit malveillant d'un
esprit malsain
j'ai toujours aimé la justice j'ai
toujours aimé aider les autres et est ce
que j'ai pu dire avant forcément ça peut
être très mal dit et c'était c'était
sûrement mal dit puisque ça ça a été
tournée d'une manière absolument
malsaine mais je changerais rien parce
qu'aujourd'hui je suis ce que je suis
par rapport à ce que j'ai pu être avant
donc si je m'amuse à changer le passé
encore et encore au final j'en sors
jamais je suis la première dans mon
genre à arriver à la télé avec avec un
talent avec un physique avec une
apparence avec une certaine vision donc
je suis arrivé je savais ce que je
voulais j'étais là je voulais chanter
c'est comme ça c'est moi et en fait je
crois que ça a effrayé
beaucoup de personnes une minorité en
fait qui n'est pas prête à voir une
qu'on se le dise une femme de confession
musulmane hockey dans sa peau claire
dans sa peau et qui n'est pas soumis à
son père venir son mari en l'occurrence
voilà j'ai pas mon père qu'est là où tu
ne m'as tête et qui me dit ouais tu vas
mettre ton foulard c'est ça en fait ça
déconstruisait tous les clichés qu'on
avait sur cette femme soumise et moi
j'arrivais la commune comme une nouvelle
voie une possibilité mais en fait j'ai
envie de dire je suis pas du tout une
suis pas du tout un cas unique y a plein
plein de filles dans mon genre est pas
une fille dans mon cas comme ça qui sont
épanouis qui sont très bien dans leur
peau qu'on leurs convictions religieuses
et leur passion dans la vie c'est juste
que moi j'ai été mises en lumière
et comme j'ai été mis en lumière et que
je l'assumais et ben c'est ça qui a
dérangé c'est que ça donnait une trop
bonne image
une belle image d'une possibilité en
france d'une nouvelle jeunesse et
ça a dérangé en france parce que je
pense qu'il ya des courants qui sont pas
prêts à voir ça